lagence des maladies de l'union
européenne appelle à prendre urgemment
des mesures elles redoutent une
situation sanitaire difficile ces deux
prochains mois en france c'est un record
depuis les 11 août dernier plus de 30000
nouveau quelques vides ont été
enregistrés hier illustration de la
reprise épidémique l'exécutif s'est
réuni en conseil de défense sanitaire ce
matin le ministre de la santé annoncera
demain de nouvelles mesures les
précisions de notre reporter katia pique
nique
gabriela talent le porte parole du
gouvernement a commencé par évoquer une
situation épidémique qui se détériore
avec un taux de reproduction de 1,6 il a
décrit un début de vagues fulgurante
plus 80% d'infection en une semaine
vingt mille cas par jour en moyenne 30
milles hier et cela correspond aux
chiffres du pic épidémique de la
quatrième vague pour le porte parole du
gouvernement la situation à l'hôpital
est le nerf de la guerre selon lui on
peut éviter la saturation hospitalière
en prenant des précautions
il explique aussi que les vaccins ont
prouvé leur efficacité ou l'écoutent
vaccin réduit drastiquement le risque de
formes graves et que nous observons donc
plus la même corrélation corrélation que
dans les précédentes vagues les trois
premières entre le nombre de
contaminations et le nombre de formes
graves qui nécessitent une
hospitalisation une étude israélienne
récentes confirment encore une nouvelle
fois l'efficacité de la vaccination et
du rappel le risque d'hospitalisation et
de cinquante trois pour mille pour un
non vaccinés il chute à 9,6 pour mille
pour en vacciner deux doses et il chute
à 1 8 pour mille pour un vacciner trois
doses cela confirme une nouvelle fois
l'efficacité de la vaccination et
l'efficacité du rappel les annonces
qu'en dirait bien pour le moment rien de
très drastique le gouvernement souhaite
éviter les restrictions type jauge
confinement couvre feu l'idée étant bien
sûr de sauver les fêtes de fin d'année
alors gabriela talent a annoncé un
renforcement des mesures barrières
l'aération le port du masque en
intérieur et extérieur autre mesure
l'accélération de la campagne de rappel
va-t-elle concerner tout le monde ou
juste les plus de 40 ans pas d'autres
précisions aujourd'hui si ce n'est une
discussion avec les présidents des
groupes parlementaires de l'assemblée du
sénat dans l'après midi demain avec les
associations d'élus et les ministres
devront aussi consulter leur secteur il
y aura également un renforcement du pass
sanitaires et la gabriela talent l'a
bien fait comprendre
il a dit qu'il souhaitait mettre
davantage de contraintes sur les
non-vaccinés plutôt que sur les
personnes qui prenaient leurs
responsabilités
olive et veyran le ministre de la santé
apportera d'autres précisions demain
lors d'une conférence de presse des
nouvelles mesures